[Musique]
bonsoir baratin par kenya merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france ont
bien de l'entendre un plus de 60000
spectateurs autorisés dans les tribunes
de wembley pour les demi finales et la
finale de l'euro de foot 1 le 6 juillet
prochain
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète
hirsch arrière toute
la raison de cette inquiétude mais c'est
que maintenant les tests
malgré toutes les mesures anti corrida
qui auront été mises en place pour la
contamination reste possible
il ya beaucoup de motifs de
préoccupation on peut prendre toutes les
précautions du monde autant le stade
sans pouvoir contrôler l'accès au stade
ni booth lettrines les restaurants lieux
de boissons le match ensuite à nouveau
les restes vraiment népal des transports
au sénat
ce sont des lieux le risque et nous ne
savons pas ce que forment les gens ne
sont pas les feuilles à contrôler ce
sont donc des motifs de préoccupation
d'autant battant cagnac on rappelle que
le variant delta représente désormais
c'est énorme un peu 2 90 % des
infections outre-manche on sait que
l'euro c'est un événement où les
nationalités se brasse qu'on le veuille
ou non c'est un danger évidemment pour
le royaume uni bien sûr mais aussi pour
les autres pays européens
hier c'était oui tout à fait car partout
où il ya des foules à ces rassemblements
la propagation du virus fait prendre
place comme il vaut mieux comme position
de dire que nous avons pris toutes les
mesures possibles
mais malgré toutes ces mesures incluent
défense
ça c'est la contamination le violeur se
répondent nous devons être aussi
prudents que nous pouvons c'est la seule
solution
le problème c'est que même si nous
pouvons contrôler le stade
le match en lui même les spectateurs à
ce qu'ils sont dans le stade il est
impossible de savoir ce qui se passera
en dehors du stade
il s'est vraiment là qui le risque alors
justement le gouvernement au lieu
d'interdire l'événement le ministre de
la santé lui préfère en appeler à la
population idy plus de 300000
rendez-vous sont disponibles dans les
jours à venir pour se faire vacciner
contre le comider couper l'herbe sous le
pied du variant delta c'est ce qui ce
qu'il dit ce sont ses mots c'est la
bonne solution même si voilà ces lois
vient d'appeler mais est ce que le
vaccin est la bonne solution parce que
ça va suffire à kingston et causent
souvent je le pense car jusqu'à présent
donné les montants qu'ils dépassent 1
sont efficaces face aux variants blâmer
variant delta plus belles mars il a mené
contaminés alors la maladie et d'un
grave c'est mon avis pas signé et cela
il vite les formes graves de l'aco vide
le vaccin est un très bon moyen de se
protéger et nous devons vacciner autant
que possible les personnes qui ne le
sont pas encore
effectivement il ya un effet protecteur
bénéfique
je me souviens qu'avant que la situation
se gâte en royaume uni vous étiez le
premier à nous dire que vous vous
inquiétiez du fait que le pays ne
fermait pas facilement et assez tôt ses
frontières avec l'inde
aujourd'hui c'est la chancelière
allemande qui déplore l'absence de
règles communes au sein de l'union
européenne concernant les déplacements
de deux personnes alors justement que
l'europe s'inquiète de ce variant delta
est ce qu elle a clairement raison de
s'inquiéter
elle a tout à fait vous ne pourrez pas
la propagation de ce virus à mais nous
pouvons se ralentir le virus et pour
ralentir le viol us il faut restreindre
les mouvements de personnes d'un pays à
l'autre
eos 1d pu notamment les mouvements entre
des pays ne va rien delta circule
beaucoup la chancelière merkel a tout à
fait raison d'être inquiet
ok il faut contenir endiguée et
restreindre la circulation du virus dans
toute l'union européenne ce qui est très
difficile car il ya de très nombreuses
frontières à contrôler alors pour
l'instant à ce delta est peu présent en
europe à part au royaume-uni 1 4% en
belgique 6% en allemagne très
minoritaire en france
est-ce que clairement c'est une question
de temps pour que nous aussi on se
prennent finalement une nouvelle vague
en raison de ce delta on peut encore
l'éviter selon vous la salle face ou
telle unité se réunit deux aces matin
maintenir un restaurant ce moto 2 3 de
mesures de prévention excellent trio de
fax mais aussi elle va par exemple
possible
l'histoire de personnes que possible
afin de savoir au moins que les
personnes vulnérables les personnes les
plus susceptibles de développer des
photographes se protéger il fonctionne
comme la solution ce serait des mesures
de contrôle de la contamination et la
vaccination où ils en sont on peut
protéger la population concernant
l'orientation de bilan afin de voir
apparaître une hausse des cas parmi les
personnes encore non vaccinés cela va
arriver on voit dans tous les pays
que ce sont les populations les moins
favorisées qui vont se faire vacciner ça
reste l'un des points d'achoppement
comment convaincre cette population d'y
aller extrêmement important que c'est
important que les auteurs les autres
responsables dont les personnalités
politiques communiquent informe et forme
les populations le père soit il ne faut
pas les forces et cela d'un quart sens
mais il faut leur montrer les bénéfices
de la vaccination par rapport à la
dangerosité douter les contaminations et
la dangerosité de ce qu'on appelle le
comique les fameux grave et les locaux
vides sont montrés très dangereux et il
faut montrer aux gens que le vaccin
n'est pas dangereux et que on a vraiment
intérêt à se faire vacciner
merci baraque pendant canadien d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france